people never see the biggest planet or
neck
how long has it been six weeks in the
air only the Quinjet touchdown at a
record for supper one it is we're
supposed to be even longer you know who
called us in I do you okay now I know
something's up
I got word from contacts in law
enforcement Los Angeles two civilians
were violently killed mysterious burns
heads bashed in spine Polaris many
conflicting accounts but all agree it
was odd odd isn't that our wheelhouse
he's right why call us in we could be
headed to the sea right now to confirm
the presence of an enhanced person if
there is one if it checks that we back
in tack we handle these on the fly
didn't exactly want to send us out on
the wire may you're not sharing again
that would be a really good time to
share the police also have another
victim in custody critical condition
under sedation he mentioned seeing a
girl saying it was the one from the news
quake which you didn't want to send over
the wire you were pulled off Daisy's
case the director thinks she slipped
through her fingers too many times the
director thinks you let her know we
pursued her she was a ghost well in His
infinite wisdom he says you're now
forbidden to but you're telling us just
because you just want to do something
about it
[Music]
look I can bury this until the official
police report comes through it'll buy us
a few hours of lead time get to LA step
around yeah we have an active in human
asset in Los Angeles that's due for a
check-in soon enough it'll justify our
presence there but as soon as the
reports filed they'll pull us out and
the Armed Forces will be sent in after
her with orders to kill to kill if she's
responsible for these bodies
that's not Daisy's mo the world knows
her as quake and quake is an outlaw who
takes down banks and bridges oh come on
with my mathematics the watchdog's
trying to take down their funding
they're their escape routes
regardless you should feel up and get
back up in the air ASAP find it before
the military does something bad or Daisy
does something worse
hey youtubers is Charlie so Marvel has
posted the first couple minutes for
episode 1 of agents of shield it's
titled the ghost as in Ghost Rider so
let's break it down
pretty cool them to drop the first
couple minutes of the episode as you can
tell they're talking about Daisy she's
still on the loose just going after
former Hydra infrastructure like their
banks just things that they used to move
weapons around so she's been kind of
like a rogue social justice warrior
since the end of last season the
government's getting upset about all the
stuff she's destroying so they order
shield to bring her in or kill her and
then here's where you get into the Ghost
Rider stuff because the title of the
first episode is the ghost so it's all
about introducing his character is that
they're finding bodies that Ghost Rider
has destroyed now he doesn't just kill
people he burns their soul it's way
worse than that so one of my favorite
lines out of this whole clip is where
they talk about spines being ripped out
of bodies so I know they moved the show
to 10:00 p.m. meaning that they can get
more graphic with the stuff they show I
don't know if we're going to get to see
Ghost Rider rip someone's spine out of
their body but he is gonna Massacre a
lot of people so what it sounds like is
happening is that they're trying to
track Daisy down before the regular
shield agents can get to her they'll
come to a head with the Ghost Rider
character so the team Coulson Daisy and
Ghost Rider all converged in the same
place by the end of the episode or at
least built up to that moment if it's
going to be a two-part premiere and
they're just breaking a really big story
into a couple different pieces the other
really big thing if you didn't know this
is actually pretty cool Jason O'Mara is
the new director of shield
it's Batman day today so happy Batman
day for one but two he is the voice of
Batman in a lot of the DC animated
movies so Batman is now the director of
shield in the way they explained it is
is because shield has now been real
Ajith amazed after the events of Civil
War like the Avengers went under
government supervision there's no need
for shield to be off the radar anymore
so like you can rewatch that clip at the
end of this and you'll see that person
yelling at new grunts the fact that
they're legitimate now means that they
have manpower again meaning that there
are a whole bunch of potential new red
shirts for people
ghostrider to kill during the season
totally on accident but the thing about
Jason O'Mara's character is that they've
talked a lot about what he's doing in
why he's the director not Coulson like
everybody still thinks that Coulson is
dead including a lot of the big villains
in the world so they want to keep it
that way they want to keep Coulson off
the radar so to speak so that's why they
need a new public face of shield and
that is Jason O'Mara but as you can see
he's also running it too like he's
ordering Coulson around so he's a pretty
big deal they have not revealed the name
of his character because they said it's
a huge deep cut from the Captain America
comics and I'm wondering if he is Jim
Hammond the original Human Torch his
costume from the comics appeared in the
first Captain America movie like in that
case there so maybe that's who he is but
whoever he is he's a big callback to the
classic Captain America comics so
they'll probably revealed that in the
first episode and we'll also find out
what's happening with the Inhumans in
the larger context Joss Whedon implied
they're going to have access to some of
the royal family but they're doing
ghostwriter someone who was previously a
movie character so it sounds like
they're going to have a lot more fun
with comic book characters they normally
wouldn't have been able to do in
previous seasons but they're also tying
in with the Doctor Strange movie
thematically what's happening with the
Marvel Universe you're not going to see
Benedict Cumberbatch guest star on
agents of shield like that's not going
to happen but a lot of the stuff that's
happening on shield will be mirrored
with stuff that's happening in Doctor
Strange so supernatural character Ghost
Rider is kind of the backdoor to that so
just keep your eyes peeled for Doctor
Strange Easter eggs or name drops and
I'll try include as many as possible
when I post my episode 1 video which
would be Tuesday night shield is one of
the first big shows that's back so
episode 1 video post Tuesday night
Gotham is premiering on Monday night so
I'll do a video for that too so Gotham
and agents of shield on Monday and
Tuesday the week after that Luke Cage
premieres and then the week after that
pretty much everything else is coming
back so I'll be sure to remind people
with the schedule is is stuff rolls out
but the Captain America giveaway still
going on all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video it's just a gift certificate
for the value of the Captain America
blu-ray so tomorrow was probably gonna
happen is new Game of Thrones and maybe
like a Shazam Justice League video
because a lot of people have been
wondering
if Alan Ritchson has been teasing that
he's playing Shazam I don't necessarily
believe it but I'll totally do a video
for that tomorrow what you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to learn
all about the big Avengers Easter Egg
that the Spider Man homecoming people
just dropped and you can click here to
learn all about the Justice League stuff
the Zack Snyder drop today thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight